yeah cassandra how's it going good
great i'm psyched um and now we're
immediately going to go to like more sad
news and we'll talk about a lot of
antifa stuff
so um all right we'll just
try and get back on track i guess thanks
for hanging out smash the like button
again because
we working we're working very hard in
real time you're watching us
and uh joining me of course is cassandra
fairbanks not for the fifth time
and uh let's talk about the first story
man jake gardner
this is a sad one actually i cover
heartbreaking things
every day like i cover terrible things
and tragedy
and things that really upset me but this
one hit me in like a completely
different way
i mean i was sobbing while i wrote it
i'm gonna get really angry
as we talk about this just so you know
jake gardner was a small business owner
the businesses nearby his bar were
attacked
his dad i guess was telling the guys
like back off and like shoved on him or
something
and then you there's video of all this
the dude runs up and and just
decks gardner's dad a 70 year old man
70 year old man so garner shows that
he's got a weapon
these guys start walking towards him and
you of course you've seen one of the
videos where you can hear the audio yeah
and he's saying don't do it
right he's like don't do it don't do it
he's backing up retreating
and they attack him they attack him
they knock him into the ground he fell
in water i think right he found like a
pot on the street
and then this guy i think his name is
james skurlock correct yes
jumps on his back with the with his hand
i'm on his neck
uh gardner had already warned them
several times
he fired two warning shots two guys run
off dude jumps on his back and then he
switches the gun to his left hand
reaches over and fires
shooting the dude in the clavicle
killing him
they took everything from this guy so i
don't know do you want to you want to
tell us just like elaborate on the
details cause you've been talking to his
friends and stuff
yeah so that he lost his business he
lost uh
his everything his apartment i mean
everything everything was taken from him
i mean
friends turned on him his whole life was
uprooted you know
um i mean acquaintances people that he
knew like people who went to his bar
people who worked at his bar
all these people were coming out against
him and it was really sad because it was
so
it was so clear that it was self-defense
and
why he got indicted yeah well the
district attorney originally said
that this is self-defense it's clear-cut
you know he didn't do anything wrong
and then protesters started showing up
at the district attorney's house they
were threatening to riot
it was a disaster and so the city caved
in and they hired a special prosecutor
he decided to bring it before a grand
jury came up with four charges i think
the maximum he was going to face was 95
years um
and then the day outrageous the day he
was supposed to turn himself in they
found him
reportedly with a self-inflicted gunshot
wound yeah and 20 minutes from portland
what was he doing on the west coast um
well he had
lost everything so i've heard that he
was staying with his uncle
out on the west coast that's crazy yeah
he had so the landlord kicked him out
yeah i hope that landlord never rents
that property again
and the landlord for the bar the the bar
where he was least or the building
that's what i mean
yeah but his apartment too yeah his
apartment yeah
wow wow so and gofundme shut his shut
his defense down yep but you can raise
all the bail money you want for
rioters kamala harris can ask for bell
money for the rioters
yeah this is why we're in the middle of
nowhere and why we actually struggled to
get the stream going today
and why ian can't talk and why lydia
can't talk either because the mics
aren't working
my mic's working you think it's working
i think so yeah are you sure yeah
well i mean i think your talk hi hey
everybody i finally got a chance to say
something
what's up hey can man handle that mic
you can like pull it forward
i think your mic is working people are
like ian we can hear you okay enough
but we can't hear ourselves okay anyway
anyway i'm like we're
we're past all of that we're fast we're
in the middle of nowhere we're in the
middle of nowhere because
this is not the first time we saw a
story of someone being attacked by the
mob
and this is the craziest thing this dude
was retreating backing away
don't do it and then he fired warning
shots he clearly did not want to hurt
anybody
the craziest thing about the indictment
of this guy is that they claimed that
it was the use of a firearm while
committing a felony and the felony was
terroristic threats
and the terroristic threats were him
saying don't do it back away
yeah and that he was uh
on fire patrol like making sure that his
building didn't burn down
yep like what on what planet are we on
what country are we in
this happened to you yeah they came to
your house
and then their allies and media
desperately tried to claim you made it
up yeah they ran cover for the people
who came to my house
they were like oh they just shot
fireworks down the street like you know
where i lived
i was not in downtown i wasn't in a very
city
area um relative to this
we're gone like we're in the mountains
now but
i mean they claimed to have talked to my
neighbors said that it didn't happen
when in reality like alan bakari from
breitbart and my boyfriend went and
talked to my neighbors and they were
like
no we didn't talk to he made it up any
right wing outlet or any right
and they were like no we like you like
we came to your halloween party why
would we trash you
yeah and they were the only house with a
blm sign in their window so it was like
you made up this entire story to run
cover for people who just
terrorized my child to specify what
exactly
happened i know a little bit about it so
i was trolling pretty hard on twitter
admittedly it went pretty hard during
the riots
and the night that they burnt down the
church in the white
in dc people had posted my address and
my phone number
and they were threatening to come to my
house they were threatening me they were
threatening my child
and i was pretty nervous about it but i
had gotten this kind of stuff a lot
before so i was like whatever it'll be
fine
you know i'm just going to keep a loaded
gun next to my bed but no big deal
4 am hits riders pretty much dispersed
and then all of a sudden my whole house
just like lights up from
all sides and they they were shooting
commercial grade fireworks
my house i mean i thought it was
gunshots but they said later that
you know they it was probably just the
really large fireworks
um but then they they started banging on
my windows and
um how did they find out where you lived
uh
through subpoenas that got some sleep
from people trying to get my
conversations with julian assange
actually but wow that's a whole other
story
are these people pro assange i don't
even understand
no are they pro anything no it's such a
weird i just want to tear everything
down
yep i know yeah i i have no other way to
explain it
so i'll tell you a funny story i was in
a conversation with some uh buddies
you know like ian we we uh we share a
living space along with many other
people
and so the day that happened the morning
it was no no it was like afternoon okay
but the day it was the afternoon
and i was talking to everybody and i was
like listen man things are getting
spicy okay so you need to understand
that
the show that i do the the the people
that we have come through here and stuff
this is probably going to be a target
too like you were trolling pretty hard
not like you deserved or anything like
that but you know i don't
and so i was just like i don't think it
matters i think they'll come for you
when they decide
whether it's now because cassandra's
pushing back or because i do a story
they don't like
and general sentiment i guess from
everybody was like okay
you know we'll see whatever sure
and then the next day i took a bunch of
my recurve bows
and i like just propped them up got them
ready and
the general sentiment was what's going
on and the general response was they
showed up to cassandra fairbanks house
they were banging on windows they were
firing fireworks at it
and it's only a matter of time before
they start targeting
lesser like i don't want to say lesser
known in regards to us because we're not
like mainstream media or anything
but like tucker carlson's like the
top-tier biggest cable channel period
right our cable show so they went to his
house right another one other people's
houses
it's going to keep moving in the window
of acceptable discourse where you're
safe from this
is going to get smaller and smaller
chat's asking to turn cassandra up a
little bit and when you
have it point it right at your face is
this better yeah speak into it like it's
a tube
also i have uh tooth aligners in i'm
talking terribly
this is the problem of not having
headphones yeah because you can hear
yourself
and then you're like oh i'm really quiet
and when you don't have it you know yeah
but uh we're we're in the middle of
nowhere having trouble with setting up
the studio simply because
i mean i could be honest it's a
combination if i work too much if i took
one day off we could have built the
studio properly but i'm like no
i'm gonna keep working i have another
studio downstairs and uh
getting away from the city is because
this is happening and as things have
gotten crazier and crazier
i'm i'm just like dude i'm not having it
i know i've decided a million times but
it's not just this omaha omaha bar owner
they went to that guy's house in
milwaukee yep
let's talk about this guy in milwaukee
so uh
what what was the what was the story he
was a racist
they they claim that he was racist but
he got into a fight with his black
neighbor
um don't know what it was about i'm
assuming it was some kind of like
neighborhood dispute about the yard or
whatever
she told a bunch of people on social
media that he was racist
and there's this uh protest group
in milwaukee and they're throwing like i
think it's justice protest parties or
something
and what it is is they're doxing people
posting their addresses in this group
and showing up on their front lawns to
protest
and terrify them and intimidate them and
threaten them i mean they were outside
his house for three hours
screaming threats into a bullhorn this
is a regular guy yeah regular yeah
they said he's a racist three hours in
front of his house
and he got arrested yep and the police
were like nowhere to be found they were
streaming the whole time proudly
streaming themselves threatening him
and he's sitting inside his house didn't
confront them didn't say anything to
them
but he had he visibly had a shotgun yeah
like he
he's pointed at the window i don't think
he opened the window though yeah i'm not
even sure if he really like pointed it
or if he was like adjusting his position
like maybe he was moving getting off his
elbow it wasn't like he was like
i think he pointed it i don't know i
think he pointed i don't care if he did
personally
like get off my lawn i'm that lady so
we so there's there's so much here that
is deeper than just this story
and first i'll just say my biggest
criticism is how the media
runs defense all the time non-stop
so this this this pro these mobs that
have been showing up and doing this
they've gone to other houses where in
one instance they
almost burnt it to the ground they set
it on fire and there was a mob
outside two people got shot i should say
people two two teenagers
fourteen-year-olds got shot during this
like
they were looking for missing girls that
weren't actually missing this is the
same group
same group same group same guy same
community activist
and so that's that's the point so
imagine you're sitting at home it's
saturday night
you cracked open a couple brews you're
watching you know watching the game or i
don't know
that guy probably was not watching the
game he's probably watching netflix or
something what's on amazon i don't know
no netflix netflix no no he got rid of
netflix he's got a trump flight that guy
got rid of
the mob shows up it's the same guy who
was at the other house
where they shot two kids and they set
fire the house twice
and so what's he thinking he grabs his
gun right then they say because he was
drunk
and so this is something that lydia
brought up was a really good point
imagine you're chilling at home and
you're drinking
and you're not wasted but you have a
couple beers and then a mob shows up and
threatens your safety
i'm not saying that the writers or the
black lives matter people are going to
break in or anything i'm just saying
let's imagine a scenario where you
happen to have been drinking when
someone's about to break into your house
yeah if you defend your house then are
they gonna say oh you're drunk sorry
yeah it's insane even if you even if he
was wasted
he should be able to defend his house
it's it's
just incredible to me it seems like
because they were on the street
and not on his property they definitely
entered onto his property they did oh
yeah
they were definitely on his lawn at
several points wow
like they were not you know respecting
property boundaries or anything
they don't believe in property yeah did
you see that black lives matter removed
their mission statement
no i did not yeah it's gone from their
website apparently whoa
that was the only thing i had on their
side their mission statement yeah
disrupting the nuclear family it was
about economic equality they had a few
points where i was like how can i get
how can i understand what they want like
positively
i don't trust anything these people have
to say anymore not like i trust
republicans all that much
but when they repeatedly say that
they're fighting for justice but then
literally attack
like they're not they're not fighting
against racism they're attacking black
and brown people
when i i think it's i think i i have to
wonder if the goal is to make
more and more people just vote for
donald trump
i would not be voting for trump this
year if this wasn't happening
really yeah what's that about the julian
assange thing i voted for trump i
you know i believe in a lot of his
policies his campaign promises i am
right-wing
but um i'm very upset with what he's
doing to julian assange and i would sit
it out in protest
if democrats weren't running around
being domestic terrorists
were you always you weren't always
right-wing no you know
i know but for the audience you were
like a big bernie
yeah you were out there with black lives
matter yeah i mean
i was writing for a libertarian website
that was pretty
harsh on police and pretty anarchist
bent
and i went covered ferguson and i was
very upset about the kelly thomas case
in orange county which was a man who
actually
was innocent and was beat to death by
police
in a very shocking video um so when they
first came out i was like cool people
are gonna talk about this maybe we can
get justice for kelly thomas awesome
rock on do your thing and then i just
as i watched what they were doing i just
became more and more
disenchanted with it and completely
repelled me eventually
i remember you told me a story about how
you got you actually got attacked for
being white
yeah and you're not even i mean i don't
know what you're
sort of you you told me that's what it's
called so i was like oh okay
yeah but they but like it's it's it's
kind of interesting how
when they started attacking other
minorities who didn't agree with them
they started saying it's whiteness
instead of being inside if you are white
it used to be like you're a white male
then it was like when candace owens
would come around or or people like you
or me it's like
it's white ness yeah like now it's just
the concept of
which can be adopted by anybody no
you're white ian well i've got a friend
who's a
black albino it's the most mind-bending
thing he's african-american probably
white and they're already on their
charts he's just white as me but he
identifies as
black it's just not i mean it depends if
he's right or left-wing
then they'll figure out what his color
or what you know his ethnicity
is i think maybe the whole goal is to
just remove this concept of
race in general like they say it they
don't believe race exists they think
there's no genetic component to any of
it
and then when you start saying when they
start saying that like
what remember that article i think was
having a post that black men are the
white people of black people
yeah yeah things like that it's like i
think that they genuinely have an issue
with white people
so i mean i don't know if i agree on
that one i think that they gen
genuinely like it's becoming
very apparent that there's a massive
disdain particularly for men but for
women too the whole karen meme and
what they did to amy cooper um they
there's just this
weird it's almost like revenge like
they're trying to get revenge
i don't think i don't i don't think it's
revenge i think it's just a cultist
scapegoat yeah well they simultaneously
say that donald trump is
skateboarding immigrants it's like when
you talk about all this whiteness and
white privilege
like literally the concept of whiteness
where they
you saw this thing in the smithsonian
where they claimed that
time and hard work are traits of white
people it's like
yeah okay like so there's an old joke
i don't know if you guys have seen the
john cleese thing where he's like
this is a simplified version it's an old
joke and then it's been expanded upon
where he's like
if you want to be a right-wing fellow
here's a list of people you can hate
and then he goes through all the people
like the right supposedly hates and then
he's like now if you find yourself
wanting to be a left-wing extremist
here's a list of people that you can
choose to hate and then he goes through
a list of people and the funny the joke
about it is that at the end he says
he's like when he's talking about when
he's talking about the right-wing people
i'm sorry the people that right wing
hates he ends with and moderates
and then when he goes to the left-wing
people he ends once again with moderates
like both sides hate him
but there's an expanded joke where it's
like
if you want to be a traditional
conspiracy theorist
all right then you're angry at the
illuminati
they control the banks they start all
the wars they're responsible for all the
impression
oppression now if you're a neo-nazi well
then you just replace
illuminati with the word jew if you're
an occupy wall street activist you
replace the word you with the one
percent
if you're an intersectionalist you
replace the one percent with white
people or whiteness
they always say basically the same
things but all of the groups they
believe are oppressing them and none of
it is true
it's just extremism but i will say it's
kind of coming full circle too it's
really interesting
in that uh a book i don't know if you
guys saw the uh in defense of looting
have you seen that one i've seen
apparently there's like a portion of it
where they say
that uh jewish people and asians are
like the face of capital or something
that's their claim
and it's like that sounds horribly
racist and anti-semitic where are you
going with this
the new black panther party protested a
chinese restaurant in d.c
remember 101 was that why i don't even
remember why they were just
but it was a few months ago they went it
was uh
what's the name of the restaurant is in
dc
i've been there before really good um
they
show they're protesting it i don't
remember but it was like the most
ridiculous thing and they were i think
they were claiming that like
yeah yes that's what it was why were
they protesting it
i wrote about it and i'm completely
blanking it's been a really
extreme day today we're definitely gonna
get this all fixed and then have you
come back later in the week for sure
but they um yeah they're saying
basically that asians are white people
now too so that's why that's why they
say
yeah black indigenous black comma
indigenous comma people of color
asians don't count yeah so it's really
bad for someone like me you know like
they really hate me
yeah i was at uh i was at a a protest in
i think it was seattle at uw university
of seattle washington
and there was a guy who was like ranting
about
the the goal of the nazis was to merge
with the asian race to create
and i'm like wait wait hold on what you
just made that i was like dude
the nazis and japanese were like allied
and i'm like they never actually
met at any point in battle like they
were separated by half the planet
like that's ridiculous the nazis were
like all about like they're ridiculously
racist
that's not true but they just make these
things up to explain why it is
that asian immigrants do really well i
learned something really crazy too
filipino immigrants to the us make way
more on average than the average
american
really yeah that surprised me that's
interesting
it surprised me because like of all of
the
east asian nations southeast asian i
would have assumed that like filipinos
would come here and be on par with like
the average
salary average is average right they do
better
and i think it's it's i don't i don't
look at the numbers for all the other
you know countries of origin but i guess
there's probably
like um legal immigrants probably make
more money
i mean they're willing i i don't think
it's anything to do with with uh
here's i think what it has to do with is
that these people are in their country
saying
i'm going to work hard to go somewhere
to improve myself that kind of
perseverance and mentality
they then come here and they keep
working they don't stop and they find
that path to opportunity
but i found that really really
interesting because there's there's
uh there's a lot of arguments when the
left tries to talk about asian people
and say that they're not
you know uh they're not that they're not
marginalized group that they're actually
oppressors because they're so privileged
they're typically we're talk
they're typically talking about chinese
immigrants and indian immigrants
and they ignore all of the other more
like less wealthy
asian nations but even the immigrants
from many of these countries do better
than the average american i think we we
as americans
have a culture problem where we don't
teach our kids to work hard
thus we end up with a bunch of people
marching around smashing things
arguing that they they're owed something
they deserve things but they're not like
they're not working towards it
right i'll tell you what i'll give you a
piece of advice too the best advice is
just do stuff
because like i could have said we're not
going to do the show because we couldn't
because everything was broken and i'm
like i don't know whatever man we're
going to do it and we're going to have a
broken night or whatever he's got to
work hard you got to you got to try you
got to make stuff happen
but now it ends up where these people
are getting into government
they're controlling schools institutions
and you know what
you know i'll tell you this i'm going to
make a bold bold statement
part of me when these people yell like
cops are bad or whatever
i immediately think man these cops who
who uh
arrested small business owners these
cops who went to mccloskey's house and
took their guns
i mean those cops for sure i think are
bad yeah and it's incredible
because when you're watching the video
of them in milwaukee
they they called the police on that man
these people who
hate cops and are anti-cop
they called the police and said he has a
gun in his house
and then you can hear him on his own
live stream snitching on the guy
being like he was pointing the gun he
was go get him go get him
and the cops were like okay they cheered
for the police well they pulled him out
of the house
and i was like you raving hypocrites i i
mean
we can't swear on here luckily because i
mean i have
words you can swear if you want i always
just tell people that
like so so so just so everyone who's
watching knows
i always tell people swear say whatever
you want but just realize like youtube
might penalize your content so if you're
you know you know you want to say your
thing just saying i
i have thoughts to clarify there's no
video of the guy pulling the shotgun
pointing pointing or anything well in
the video yeah the
protesters or whatever you want to call
them the
mob um they were live streaming it
themselves
onto this facebook group which is just
doxing people's addresses and things
like that um
and you could see him in the window
holding the gun okay but he never
confronted them
he never threatened them they were
threatening him with the bull horn and
the police weren't there to do anything
they didn't stop these people
they didn't i mean it was it was like a
scene from beauty and the beast when
they're like
gaston's riling up the crowd and they're
heading on horses up to the castle
except everybody was screaming
incoherently and listening to cardi b
it was really bad that's a really good
analogy
i'm not not even an adult like that's
literally what it is yeah gaston writing
the people to go
riot it's the beast he's a beast go we
gotta go bigger [ __ ] forks
and it's like some drunk dude like chung
in his living room like just watching
amazon or something who knows he must
have been terri i was terrified i have
never been more afraid and i think it's
because my daughter was there but
and you know she'll tell you all about
it if you ask her but
um i've never been more afraid because i
didn't know how many people were out
there i didn't know if they were going
to burst through my windows they were
hitting my window with like what it
sounded like
yeah and i was so afraid and
normally i can handle myself pretty well
i think i'm pretty scrappy i've been in
my share of fights
but when you don't know how many people
are out there you don't know if they're
going to come into your house you don't
know if they're going to burn your house
down
i mean there's flames shooting at my
house
it's really scary and i was holding a
gun the same way he was
and i was ready to shoot i was like the
second i see one of them pop through the
window
my life is over but my daughter's gonna
be safe it reminds me like a zombie
movie
when they they see the windows and
there's a silhouettes banging on the
window and then like the hands break
through
and you gotta like take a bat and like
bash the arms ah a lot of times you hear
the stories about stuff like that but
you always read it after the fact when
they didn't
take it to the next level right but when
you're in the moment you don't know if
it's about
uh yeah i was pleading with 9-1-1 i was
like i don't know what they're gonna do
like when are you guys gonna be here and
they were like i don't know there's
people are spread out all over the city
because there's riots
that's why and i was just like well what
am i supposed to do
and um i was like all right i'm gonna i
had a revolver so i was like i only have
six shots i'm gonna take out the biggest
one and make sure it's the men because
the women probably won't hurt my
daughter
i mean i the things that went through my
head were crazy i mean i think about it
now and i'm frightened of my own
thoughts
do you feel comfortable talking about
what kind of weapon you had i don't know
if because some people say not to
oh sorry i just said it no no no no no
i'm talking about like you said you had
a revolver yeah but what kind
you don't know i don't even remember
what it was like the caliber of bullet
really matters
i don't really want to get right right
into it i bought a bunch of guns
you sure did i sure did what was 911's
advice when you when you asked
they told me to calm down and i mean the
lady was
very like unsympathetic and i i
at one point i was like well how long is
it going to take to get here
and she was like well i'm not coming and
i'm like okay thanks
she said i'm not yeah and meanwhile my
daughter is staring at me
like what is going on and i'm telling
her to like go lay on the floor next to
her bed in case i have to
kill people and this lady's just like
well i'm not the one that's coming
i was like what what is happening
um and that was when i really like that
was the part that was the scariest i
felt like there was nobody that was
gonna come help me because
everybody you could hear sirens
everywhere but they were going to fires
they were going
you know there was riot stuff happening
everywhere that's that happened in new
york during the riots
where this guy said he called 9-1-1
because someone had broken into his
building and they were fighting
and the response he got from 9-1-1 was
sir our city is under attack what would
you have us do
yeah that's basically what they said to
me thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you